[Music]
you never feel so alive in that moment
when you go Stemler this the time you go
step up ball goes through the net the
plot goes to zeros the only way you win
playoff series is to focus on two things
that you can't control just focus on
winning a game and ultimately win in the
series
[Music]
[Applause]
what was gonna leave it all out on the
floor tonight this could have been my
last game
[Music]
everything was looking my foots going
back to OKC
time to see in the playoffs their star
gotta play like star
stars step always sundown at
defense has been outstanding throughout
the playoffs the woman right now how
much confidence to the Blazers player
their two leaders name is Hidan
those two guards were very couple great
teams and great players you know they
don't when they find out pretend like
this Danone you don't waste it
we could be looking at the end of a
dynasty we could be a couple of games
away from that or we could be looking at
maybe the greatest accomplishment that
this dynasty has ever put together stuff
doubt is getting back slightly you have
to go back to 2015 step fairy falls away
letting it fly getting it down from all
angles but he hit the biggest shot in
Toronto Raptors history this is the
reason why the brothers
whoa
went back to the lead baggage you know
game
I look at Yanis I don't know who's in
his ear but did his brother serious he
wants to be the best because he's not
playing around
Yanis it just you know like you said
it's hard to find the words what he does
for our team do like I don't know I
didn't go away in the East and I'm
looking forward to Toronto and real
walking
blazars mentally tough there more than
people
goodnight we have never and can never
say that Stefan clay don't have no heart
and that's what makes the warriors
and possible to think about healing four
times they're playing for the
kawatche he's very hungry he wants
he's playing that way that's gonna be
amazing great fan base they'll be
excited they got hard and they ready to
go